foreign
what's up guys I'm Kim BHD here I
decided to do another desk tour uh a lot
of people kept asking about the new
setup it's 2023 you haven't done an
update yet and the more I thought about
it I kept thinking okay well I've used
this setup for a long time so it feels
the same to me and most of the things
have stayed the same but then I realized
some things are different and I can walk
you guys through that stuff but then it
says a lot about the things that have
stayed especially the stuff that's been
here the longest so I'm going to walk
through kind of all of it what's new and
what's not
let's do it okay I guess we'll do left
to right because that's kind of how most
things go I have a pretty big sit stand
step desk here which means I have a lot
of space for
activities and storage but I kind of
have this mouse pad over here as like a
parking garage for things that I like
take out of my pocket so wallet keys
this is Adam Barbara's uh ping pong
paddle that he gave me if you know you
know you saw the studio video but there
is a bit of a system with smartphones
here the phones I'm using right now are
face up and on and the phones that I'm
also signed into but not actively using
our face down but then you kind of get
to the stuff that you've seen before
yamaha's hs8s
Old Faithful there's a thousand
different studio monitors I could have
switched to but these have been amazing
and I also still have the same 96
terabyte or something promised Pegasus
storage block just a bunch of hard
drives it's great the computer the
editing machine this is something that
was different from the last tour before
it was a Mac Pro that was under the desk
and this is a sit stand desk so because
the computer was on the ground all the
cables had to sort of make their way up
to the audio interface and the displays
and everything here now the computer the
editing machine is a Mac Studio on the
desk which means look at the cable
management look how nice that is you
guys can all comment nobody's gonna
roast my cable management anymore
because it's so beautiful this time also
this is the chair of choice it's still
the Herman Miller and body we've had for
a long time I also really like these
they're the most expensive chair I've
ever seen but they're also the best
chair I've ever seen so I just keep
using them this is a Grove made stand
and it's kind of cool for a couple
reasons one it's double wide you could
put the my monitors on top but I put
them under and it kind of lets me just
take some stuff off of the desk so more
surface area and it happens to just
perfectly perfectly frame the Mac Studio
that was a total coincidence but it's
pretty much the exact height of the
computer so it worked out the opal C1 is
still here Pro display xdrs they have
been awesome as well Belkin wireless
charger this is a one magsafe one
regular qi charger Apple watch charger I
am still a three input kind of guy with
the keyboard which is a kikron q1 which
is customized a little bit shout out to
keycron and it's wired and that's fine
but there's a track pad over here and a
mouse knock them over here look at this
this this Frame right here I've been
asked a lot about you guys know the um
the histogram t-shirt right it's got a
several different waveforms on it that
is from an actual photo
of this red mouse pad with a black mouse
on it Apollo twin all the way to the
side and this is probably the last cool
thing
uh my headphone stand it's just a clamp
on the side of your desk anyone can do
this because my HD 650s their open back
I use them for editing and I just pop
that over there so that's the desk setup
some new some old but I also do want to
talk about
the bag so let's go do that
all right so this is the bag
same theme this is my everyday carry
like literally I bring this with me
every single day to the studio and
around
um but it's kind of the same idea it's
most of the same stuff just one year
more worn in and then you can see the
stuff that I've had for multiple years
versus the new stuff the bag is the same
thing I'll sort of talk through it if
you haven't seen the previous video this
is the peak design everyday carry 20
liter version there's a bigger one I I
swear by this bag it's it's kind of the
best backpack I've ever used we did
manage to get a bit of a custom version
of it which has red stitching on the
outside and on the inside uh water
bottle on the outside pocket now look at
this this is uh what I would call
Tina why am I not call it a patina I
basically I've put this water bottle in
this backpack in and out of it so many
times that I have I mean this is the
most worn version of the water bottle
because I've had it longer than anyone
else and it slowly kind of develops this
pattern and I actually kind of think it
looks sick this is one of those
backpacks that has like three different
sections inside and can open from any
one of those sections so if I open it
from the side kind of like a
photographer's bag you can get into each
section I don't necessarily use it like
that when I'm not using a camera so I'll
go from the top because that's where
you'll find the same headphones I had
last year which are airpods Max my one
year later review of airpods Max are
they worth the
550 that they cost
um I would still say they're overpriced
but they're really great they're
comfortable and I use them a lot when
traveling so you've seen the little
airpod headphones you can wear earbuds
anywhere but when I'm flying I would
hate to forget these uh they charge by
lightning which is a huge bummer so I do
have to carry a lightning cable
everywhere all the time and that's kind
of it for the top section
this has a little
latching system so then
you get into
the bottom two sections so in the middle
this is the section where I had the
Canon R5 before I'll get into that but I
actually ditched that what I instead
have is my charging cable mess and there
should be an easier way to carry these
things but what this is is an anchor 747
which is just a wall charger that does
like 150 watts out of any of the USBC
ports super useful to fast charge
literally anything and then I have two
cables I have the magsafe charger for
the MacBook Pro and that USBC cable with
the little display on the end that shows
how many watts you're getting that's my
USBC charger and then in the bottom
because I use it less often is my
lightning to USBC cable to charge
basically just the headphones
they could have made a USBC version that
would have been nice but that's that on
the outsides I still have some other
charging accessories this is a magsafe
Duo which charges my Apple watch and
iPhone via lightning if I'm charging
both of those I have some other random
adapters and cables that I rarely need
Slash use but it's a backpack so I feel
like this is embracing a little bit of
my in case of emergency mentality and
then in the back because this has a
laptop slot
it is the same M1 Max 16 inch MacBook
Pro it's got the dbrand icon skin on it
as well as you can see nice and worn in
and that is genuinely what I carry with
me every single day everywhere I go I
use this laptop a ton I didn't upgrade
it to the M2 because I didn't really
feel like I needed it which says a lot
about how good the M1 Max is but that
that's basically what I carry I would
say there's also two little things that
I'll add that I have in my uh sometimes
carry category and so that is these two
things this is the R5 this is the Razer
Edge the R5 and the 15 to 35 are my are
still my go-to at home and quick capture
camera I capture so much stuff on
smartphones nowadays that I don't need
to carry this with me all the time it's
just extra weight especially these RF
lenses they're huge so this is sometimes
carry but uh this is also something new
and it's actually the sponsor of this
video this is the Razer Edge so this is
kind of the perfect on the go enhanced
gaming experience for me it puts
together like a giant phone but it is
much better at gaming than a phone this
thing has a Snapdragon g3x gen 1 which
is optimized for sustained performance
and a 6.8 inch 144hz AMOLED display
which is I mean I'd rather play AAA
games on something like this than a
phone and then there's the Verizon 5G
Ultra wide band for the best possible
high speed low latency connection so you
already know me I don't play games all
the time every day but when I know I'm
gonna be traveling like this is still
the bag that I pack and take places and
this middle compartment is where I'm
slotting like the temporary use stuff so
it's great to be able to pop this out
like in a hotel room or in an airport or
on a plane or something like that there
is also a Wi-Fi only version too but you
can play on any service you subscribe to
including native Android games but also
cloud gaming services like Xbox cloud
gaming Nvidia GeForce now so that's why
having a 5G version of this is obviously
so sick because you might not always
have the Wi-Fi connection so you can
just kind of game anywhere it also
breaks down into just the display and
computer and the controller you can just
take it anywhere like I do so that's
available now at Verizon I'll link in
the description down below along with
everything else that I've talked about
in this video like I said the stuff that
sticks around longest because you don't
always get to spend a lot of time with
things uh it's good to know that it's
actually held up and lasted the test of
time so I can personally vouch for all
the things that I'm linking and talking
about there's still also going to be
lots of Alternatives I am not by any
means saying that these are the best
items I do have a lot of selection there
are lots of other headphones I'd be
perfectly happy using lots of other
computers that I'd be perfectly happy
using but
this is what I'm carrying with me
pretty much every day everywhere I go
and the tech that I use on The Daily so
for those who are asking you're welcome
that's been my Daily Tech update 2023
thanks for watching
catch you guys the next one
peace
foreign
[Music]